good morning families
I'm Greg Alba nothing John Humphrey I
know that what you want to do is watch
the frozen to brand-new trailer with two
grown men who need haircuts and who have
facial hair do you wanna watch a trailer
anyway guys before we hop into this I
want to thank everyone who has followed
us over at our patreon page over there
we do weekly Q&A as well as TV show
reaction stream alongs for many shows
that includes attack on titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man supernatural
Gotham haunting of Hell House Cobra Kai
season two and several of those shows
have reaction highlights included those
are attack on Titan my hero academia
supernatural and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as one punch man yep
these are all kid-friendly material we
are promoting that patreon page to the
right demographic right now Eddie whoo
let's watch this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
on the trolls event as the most
memorable campus
[Music]
across the enchanted lands
[Music]
all these vehicles his powers were too
much for this world
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
I won't let anything happen to her
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's gonna discover that she was like
created in a lab some way it's gonna be
all sci-fi and dark it is so a she's
gonna try to understand the source of
her powers this movie uh hunting the
origin of the ice pretty cool ending to
that seems so intense the teaser trailer
was pretty intense too wasn't it I love
that like string music they have in the
beginning
oh yeah that's a kind of thriller yeah
yeah yeah there's like desolate cold
night and she's like plunging down to
the depths it bothered to make this look
very harrowing it doesn't feel like
there is some serious peril going on I
kind of get some Zelda vibes a little
bit of like breath of the wild lives
just a little bit especially with all
these like big set pieces it looks like
they want to have cuz you've got this
like purple fire look coming up on ya
forests and stuff what's funny about in
the marketing for this I remembered the
first trailer for the frozen movie like
that 2013 one here's like a silly silly
trailer that really accurately
represented a lot of the vibe and tone
of the frozen film it didn't really
scratch the surface in terms of like how
deep it's gonna be and how meaningful
it's gonna be but it really honed in on
the silliness like a fella like in an
Olaf movie not saying I felt like
Senator Olaf but it had like low energy
and that levity to it these two trailers
have been so damn serious and barely any
Olaf's in here get ready kids
I barely remember that there were the
the trolls were in this yeah take care
of crew they're like Christoph's family
or something like that yeah they were
the best ones yeah they're the best
characters most memorable ones the movie
definitely and now they're back with
even more rock like textures the one
thing in this trailer that really took
me back to like old-school Disney but in
a modern way was Fantasia kind of
sequence yeah with the like ember
creatures that then turn into like wisps
of snow and stuff like that I
you appreciate you know it's like
they're bringing back their old stuff
and live-action so much to see some of
that tradition injected into this is
pretty cool well I really like it sir
amping up a lot of the mythology here
there seems to be a lot more of a
supernatural mystery because the first
one was a thread words grounded you know
it's like a very real it was like a
typical Disney movie in a lot of ways
and then you have the one sister who has
the powers here you know even when she's
going into the ocean and then that like
horse horse creature comes in that looks
very cool and then she's even like going
up against what a giant troll at the end
that's what it looked like to me unless
it's one of those snow monsters again
it's gone rogue against her or something
they really stayed clear that they're
gonna be going past arendale Arundale
Riverdale high pass Arundale and this
one into unknown territory I would like
to see more specific teases on the kind
of territories are going to explore
because right now the set pieces that
we've been getting there's so subtle of
teases that I'm not even sure exactly
what the unique stuff is that they're
gonna be going to explore like the
unknown as they talked about in this
trailer yeah it's like they you see some
more teases with the enhancement of her
powers which I've always been a little
bit unclear on the exact rules
yeah hundred she can freeze like almost
anything it's making anything out of
freezing stuff it's the Iceman rules
yeah Olof the life supposedly in the
first one yeah this one you're seeing
her like sort of freeze some of the rain
you're freezing like the fog apparently
you could do anything if you can free
stuff you know anything with water I
would imagine she's got some kind of
molecular control yeah this also makes
me wonder about the story cuz a lot of
the images suggest that it's gonna be a
similar kind of story structure where
it's like else it goes off on a road to
find the origin of her powers and then
on is like ah I gotta be there for my
sister's so Kristoff come on and help me
find her and you know help her out with
the mission and then maybe at the end
they're gonna be together at that
Stonehenge thing where they're partying
the fog and all that stuff it's a good
point because I don't know that I'm the
first one also was like the central
focus but then when she went away and
essentially kind of became the main
character also even though
would being the more interesting
character it was sort of still felt like
the supporting character and here this
seems to be a lot more just this is
else's movie and has barely been in
these trailers we haven't really seen
much in terms of the interplay amongst
the the cast or like the you know the
main characters in this movie it seems
like else is on her own for a lot of
this and then Anna just like I'm still
in this movie don't worry how are we
gonna be here to where the rest of the
cast no longer yeah we're gonna help out
Elsa want to see a little bit more of
that dynamic well maybe part of a mid
frozen so was so popular and special and
eventually so hated because really tired
during it in the media and I also
wondered too because it seems like
they're going a bit off-road and I am
NOT an expert on the ice queen mythology
but you know it's the first movie
borrows from an actual story one of
their notions about sisters and this one
just seems like it's about else what are
we gonna be drawing from for this is
this going to be as calibre as what you
had source material for you know like
things like that kind of worry me
because we are in a time where the
caliber and the expectation of sequels
is different but I'm not used to having
a ton of great Disney Princess sequels
that's a big part of what has me
intrigued to is because the first one
just played so much on you know rather
conventional Disney it was like a good
Disney movie good Disney maybe that like
bothered to subvert a few of the classic
Disney tropes love and princesses it
still falls in line with a lot of them
yeah and then here I think they can do
something a lot deeper a lot more
meaningful and you know concern in the
first frozen movie is I think still the
highest grossing animated movie of all
time don't snow
they'll have some free reign to really
mess around here man that animation has
really really come a lot more striking
because I thought the animation was
great in the first one but I wasn't like
dazzled by it to me I'm like Disney
learn how to make a Pixar movie this
really feels like its own thing alright
guys well are you excited for Disney's
frozen
ooh the ELSA movie comment below do you
want more Olaf in this trailer if you
liked this video hit the like button
before we wrap this up I would like to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
woman named Anissa a Lib give me a break
it's 5:30 in the morning in this I know
you recently got a boyfriend so I just
want you to know that only an act of
true love is the way to experience life
yeah once you get that in there it's
only onward and upward in your life we
were so close but you are the one who
marshmallow attacked it into your your
handsome Beau's heart right there and
just remember that if he ever commits
treason oh yeah in the relationship you
have to let it go you don't need to stay
in royal pursuit of this guy in summer
you will find all the things you need to
truly let it go you know because
sometimes relationships are a bit of a
fixer-upper
yeah love is an open door sometimes you
gotta walk through it
even though writers are better than
people for the first time in forever
you know just open yourself up to love
and celebrate Christmas with winters the
waltz we're done the trolls